well let's get more now on our top story
Syria has rejected claims it was behind
the gas attack on the rebel-held in Lib
province which killed 70 people
including many children
the Turkish justice minister has said
autopsy results from adlib show that
chemical weapons were used while medical
experts have said some victims had
symptoms consistent with nerve agents
like sarin
well I'm joined now from Coventry by dr.
Maria new in-house at a chemical weapons
expert at Warwick University good
afternoon to you and we've heard the
denials from a serie of heard from the
Syrian Foreign Minister saying that
they've either used chemicals in the
past and have no intentions of using
chemicals it is of course illegal but we
know that it still happens indeed it's a
tragedy what has happened
but since the Gotha attacks in 2013
there has been reports of usage of at
least chlorine in several instances
already so this is not unprecedented but
it is a continuation of a series of
events already's and of course a much
graver issue because it is not chlorine
but what seems to be sarin or perhaps
another toxic that has been used and how
would a nation go about hiding chemical
weapons like sarin because we know in
the past there have been inspections
where these chemicals have been handed
over to international inspectors but but
it seems that they can be a certain
amount can be concealed well first we
have to understand of course there's a
difference in in terms of chemicals that
are used that are classified as such by
the OPCW the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons chlorine
for instance is not banned on the
international law for the simple reason
that it can be stopped out in
in households even Saren isn't banned
substance sighs so are other forms of
chemical weapons so there is a
difference in terms of the
classification off of chemical weapons
to start with having said that yes the
Syria acceded to the chemical
conventions
treaty of 1993 back in 2013 and had to
comply as such effectively olbes weapons
that were listed in 2014 where they
after destroyed however they did the
fact with chemical weapons is that it
can be easily assembled these be talking
about simple chemical formula however
there is a discrepancy in its in its use
of making and distribution and
dissemination of chemical weapons that
needs and requires sophisticated and
advanced operational mechanisms such as
airplanes and historically can you sort
of take us through how chemical weapons
are deployed because there are those
observers today saying that President
Assad does have the upper hand what
really is that the reason for using this
at all or on his own people well this is
very difficult to say but the use of
chemical weapons like not so much in its
destructive its leaf or nature it likes
more in its terrifying consequences in
its representation in popular
imaginations of of such weapons is the
very fact that what these weapons do is
take away literally your breath so what
they do is they use the environment
against the user of the environment in
this case the brief or literally taking
your breath away as I said therefore it
mostly has a psychological effect on
people's imaginations rather than so
much a lethal capacity to kill of course
it kills it has historically killed but
it is predominantly the psychological
effects that lead to
that have an effect on people
the Syrian government are saying that
there were they're giving few
explanations as to why the attack could
not have been carried out by them
they're saying that an aerial attack of
this type of chemical would have covered
a much larger area and therefore that
that couldn't be consistent with an
attack by the Syrian government hmm well
what has to be done clearly and what has
been already argued for by physicians
around the world is a an independent
research needs to be undertaken in which
we will be able to collect biological
samples blood urine etc from from the
victims in order to determine what has
caused the the effects of the attack but
at the moment it's very difficult to say
without empirical knowledge on the owner
of the ground through deep German what
exactly has happened and who's to blame
for what has happened well the Turkish
government have carried out post-mortems
and they're certainly confirming that
the use of chemicals has been deployed
Syria on the other hand are saying that
the chemicals that are coming in from
Iran and Turkey and it's really their
their estimation that it's the
terrorists who using the chemicals this
is a this is of course a political
discourse which which is yet to be
determined it is at the moment it is
very difficult to say seemingly because
of the continuation of chemical web of
the use of chemical weapons by the Assad
regime it seems likely plausible that
was indeed the Syrian regime but we will
have to wait for further evidence on the
ground to see what what has led to this
chemical attack and of course it is is
indeed sarin it seems to be sarin if not
another similar toxin perhaps even more
more
more morally for more dangerous than
sarin let that ask of course these that
have led to this to this tragedy
okay talk tomorrow new in-house thank
you very much for speaking with us thank
you